good evening everyone
um welcome to our fifth and final day
of the pa data festival in functional
2020.
um this talk this evening is all about
applications in the world of python and
data science
and first i would like to give the floor
to uh bear john and hype
from the big data republic who are going
to take a
take us through exploring railway
oriented programming
in python um which i'm very curious
about so all the floor is yours
thank you so what we're going to talk
about today is railway oriented
programming
and we will basically dive into a talk
we've
seen a few weeks ago which is very
interesting um
my name is have gaming i'm a data
scientist at bdpr
and my name is benjamin brooksman and i
work as a director also for video
um yeah so at bdr we have a lot of
people who are very into
functional programming if you talk to
them they will start
throwing weird names around like mount
ads like
categories like endo functions like
functors like
and the mind just models i mean um if
you if you talk to these people you'll
soon realize you have no clue what
you're talking about
and you really don't know what they are
talking about
um but what really uh
struck me when i watched the talk was
that functional programming is not as
hard
as they make it out to be with day i
mean the people
who have to talk about the the concepts
as they are presented
um so what we're going to do today is
we're going to walk through
an important concept in functional
programming
and we're going to present it in a
different way we're going to present it
in a real way-oriented way
instead of the function of programming
with the linear and we're going to do
all this
in python
so first let's take a step back um what
actually happened was that
john um challenged me in a way he he
watched his talk and he thought it was
very interesting
um and he said you're way too kind for
me
we were fighting each other oh sure and
we're fighting each other uh
saying no functional programming is
stupid but john was saying no it's
awesome
watch the talk you'll be convinced um
because what he's said in his stalk was
basically that
the the the talk is focused on f sharp
um but he said you could do this in any
language so the the challenge was
let's watch the talk let's re-implement
both of the
the blocks he he talked about in python
let's see what
what happens basically um so we we did
we watched the talk we uh coded a lot of
examples
we uh looked what happened and that was
it
since justice we're going to classify
data and here we are
yeah um
so any
presentation like this should really
focus on
what kind of application are we going to
build and it's not really a data science
driven
application that we're going to build
this is more of a web app
type deal but the concept still relates
very well to data science as well so
what are we going to do
we're going to have a use case which is
just updating a user record
um so we have a user they make a request
to our
api or something um we receive the
request we validate it we make sure that
the email is valid and that it's in the
form that we can understand
we update the record in the database we
send an email
and then we return some result to the
user
so how would this look like in
traditional python
um if i if i were to build this
application from scratch and i would
just
be uh half an hour after that i would
have something that resembles this right
i mean
first of all i would validate the
request i would do some
lower casings localization and update
database send an email
return something and it's all well and
good but what could possibly go wrong
um we have a few calls that
could possibly return an error or could
reserve
throw an exception or basically
do something that's not uh intended in
this case
um so we have three basic points where
this could happen
first on the validate step um what could
happen is that the validation could be
incorrect for instance someone sent an
invalid email address
the update of the database could fail
the database could be done
the user record could not be found
anything um
or sending the email good could fail so
what do you normally do
you um use try accept right
so you just try to validate if you get a
validation exception you return an error
sometime same with the updated database
you check if the the update has
completed if it has not you return
another error
and with send email of course it's the
same you try to send the email
if the email server times out you just
say yeah
signed out something went wrong um
but what you see here is that our very
nice very simple code just a few lines
has basically exploded
right i mean we've we've gone from five
or six lines to
a lot um it's not great
it's not terrible i mean the overall
structure is still pretty good to read
but it has exploded a lot and the reason
for this is that we had to
combine the business logic or what to do
with the error handling logic
what to do if stuff fails um
because we have to combine these two
things the code becomes much more
convoluted and much more difficult to
read um
so what did the happy part look like
again we have five lines
four of which are just basic do this do
that
do this do that um and to be honest i
would much rather much rather write
this kind of code than this kind of code
simply because it's easy to read easier
to write
so wouldn't you much rather just write
the happy path i know i would
um so that's one of the promises of
functional programming
because if i use functional programming
i could write your entire business logic
i wrote before
as a composition of these five functions
um and be done okay sure this is still
the happy path
so if you look at this code you'll see
that there's no error handling
done in any way um so what happens if a
failure happens
well this is the same code but now i've
implemented failure
of error handling so what you'll see is
that nothing really changed
the whole promise of doing this
function composition in the railway
pattern that we're going to present
today
is that you can just write the code
you're already writing writing the happy
paths
and deal with the errors in a nice way
um so real way oriented programming what
what is it and how does it look
first let's take a step back what is a
function um
a function is something that maps
something to something else
so in this example what you'll see is
that we have a function that maps an
apple
to banana okay um and what you can do is
you can compose two functions so what
you can do is you can take a function a
you take a function b
and because in this case function a
produces a banana
you can use this banana that you get
from function a put it into function d
and get a pair so that's what you see
here if you compose the functions
um you get basically
uh how do you say it a single strike a
single track that goes from an apple
to a banana and then to a pair and this
works because the signatures in between
are compatible right i mean function a
produces a banana
function b accepts a banana and the nice
thing about it is that
this track of functions so the the
composition of function a
and function b is again a function
um and what's what's nice to realize is
that because this function maps
to a banana inside but maps to a
pair on the outside basically the
function c that we created
is now just a function that maps from an
apple to banana or sorry to a pair
so it is impossible to tell from the
outside that this function is built
from much smaller individual functions
um
how would you do this in python well as
you can see in the bottom you just have
function c which is a composition
function a and function b
pretty straightforward-ish to write in
python
um you write a compose function um you
have to do some some fun tools with
with reduce but what this does if you if
you call it with a bunch of functions is
that adjust
if you compose with function f1 f2 and
f3
it will create a function that calls f3
over f2 over f1 which you then can call
over any inputs you want so that's good
but this is still the happy part um
where we haven't talked about errors we
haven't talked about any of that yet so
i'm going to give the forward to verizon
to explain that part
thank you heart so let's say we have
parts we have functions where something
can go wrong
so how do we deal with this uh one way
of this would be drawing errors
or exceptions have you seen before but
there is a different way which you want
to present here
instead of just returning a function
we we we create a split in our track
either something goes wrong
goes because as we expect and then we
have success or something goes wrong and
then we have
a failure
this is very simple to implement let's
look at the failday function which cuts
a request
request cuts in if it is required if the
request is valid
we just wrap it in some kind of success
class and if it's not valid
we return a failure and in this failure
we put whatever we want in this
this this case a simple string telling
something went wrong with the validation
the nice thing about this is that our
validate function now always returns
an output if it's valid or not we cannot
output which we can deal with
even when things go wrong
now if we have two switches we can start
composing them
again so we have one function which
produces either success or a failure
another one which also produces sex of
failure and we can compose them together
and in the case of a failure we just
bypass how does that look like
now we get a track like this where on
either part of our composition
the function can go either on the queen
track being a success
or on a failure track
and we can of course do this with
multiple functions so we validate we
update the database you send the email
we compose them all together
creating this long track where here i
think goes right or at some point
something goes wrong
but at the end of the track we will get
either a success or a failure
that you can deal with
so composing in practice how does that
look like
we can compose single track functions no
problem as long as
the output type of validate matches the
the input type of the updated
db we can just compose two functions
together as we saw before
the same goes for double track functions
as long as the output type of validate
matches the input type of fdb
we can still compose the two functions
however we already saw that validate has
a single track input and a double track
output
while update db has also a single track
input
so how now can we compose those two
because if we put a success in update db
it will not know how to deal with that
because it expects a request not a
success and definitely not a failure
so for this we need a bit of machinery
we
sometime we somehow need to lift update
db
in in a way such that x starts extract
accepting double track inputs
how does that look like
we need an adapter for that this is a
network technique called bind
which accepts a function which which has
a normal input
such as a request but produce a
two-track output
exactly as we saw with the updp function
the adapter creates a new function which
accepts a double track
and this double track function checks
the input is the success
then it will call the original function
and if it fail if it cuts a failure it
will just
it will just pass on the input which it
got
so now with this with this bind function
we can adapt our update dbe function
by calling bind with this updb and
create a new updateddb function which
now accepts
a double track input and produce double
track output as well
so we basically lifted the
mismatch here
so what happened is that this helper
function we created here is the one
which actually makes sure that we now
accept the double track function
and that one is dealing with uh
with either the success case or with the
failure case as we saw
in an affiliate case it will not do
anything we will not call the original
function it will just pass the input
failure as an output of the of the new f
function
the important thing to realize is that
this bind function is about
shape we want to go from pure values to
reps values
wrapped in either success or a failure
but it's not about the content the
content itself
is is still as is
basically you could consider success and
failure as cards
running on this track which is still
carrying apples bananas and pairs
now that we have updated our function
our dtp function we can actually combine
them again
on the success track we still go from an
apple to banana to a pair
on the failure track we get whatever is
put out by one of those functions
when it fails but it will not be
modified by the
functions afterwards anymore so if the
function a in this case fails
then the output of function b will be
the failure of function a
as the result of function a just pass on
the field track
straight on
but switches are not the only types of
functions we want to compose
we also have canonical eyes this is a
straightforward function
nothing happens nothing can go wrong it
will just take an input and take and
produce an output
but this output is still single track
output producing a pure value
which cannot which we cannot compose
with this upd function
so here we need some additional
machinery again how does that look like
well it's almost similar to what we saw
before we need this additional track
which accepts a success or a failure in
case
the failure just passes on just ignore
the commonwealth function in that case
again this is pretty straightforward to
implement in python
this this function is typically called
map again we create an adapt function
which accepts a track
a two track in this case and in the
if the track is a success then we we
call this function
on the value which is in you know you
know success card
but then recall this canalize function
and
just return a track it returns a value
so we have to
wrap the success of the function and the
value of the function also in a success
in case of an error or in case of
failure then we just return the input
track
and the whole map function then returns
this adapter function so that we now can
since we now can compose canonicalize
the ap properly
but you might have seen that this
already looks a bit familiar
this adapt track is basically borrowed
from bind
and if you look at success
of f of track but value that's basically
a composition of f and success
this means that we basically are reusing
building building blocks we've already
seen before
so we can simplify the implementation of
map
greatly like this we compose f and
success
and then bind this function in order to
get the same result as we've got before
and this is exactly the power of
compositional programming it greatly
simplifies
the structure of your program and
therefore also makes it easy to reason
about your program which i believe is
awesome and i think i convinced hype a
bit
of this as well
so we're almost there
now that we all have all these
components of all these building blocks
we can now build our full railroad
so we start with validate which is now a
function which produces a two track
output
we lift the top canonical live function
in such a way that it can deal with this
two track inputs and produce two track
output as well
if the request is canonicalized we move
it on to our update debate
db dealing with the errors there
in the same way we deal with errors and
inputs in a send email
and finally we have this generate
response function where we move our two
track back to one
track function basically this is the
border of our domain so the same
so now we have a centralized place where
we can do
in a domain specific error in a domain
specific
manner with the errors generated by any
of the functions which came before
meaning that the central that the error
handling has become very centralized
in this particular function generate
response which should be easy to test
and can be adapted to different
different domains if you reused the
pipeline before
so in the end we end up with this
we have our business logic with our
handling
which is the composition of the success
which is a simple wrapper class because
we need to
grab our pure pure request
into a double track next
we lift our validate request into this
double track
we map canonicalize to our double track
structure
and the same for update database and
send email
and finally we we add
to generate response to this
at this point we have
a piece of business logic which is able
to deal with errors
while in the code you don't see this
dealing with errors
additionally we don't have to deal with
the
input and output handling machinery
anymore
as in you don't see the output of one
function being put in the other function
it's all hidden away
so we ended up with a quite nice
piece of software i would say which
deals with the business logic we want to
deal with
deals with the arrows as well which is
still very readable
yeah so we we started off um with a bit
of a challenge
where we would basically look what this
would look like in python right
um and i think that what we can say is
that we
went from a situation where we had to
mix the business logic with the error
handy logic um and by using this
railroad
type strategy
we've been able to move the error
handling to the complete edge of the
program
and basically do it there which means we
don't we no longer have to mix the two
um which is nice anyway right i mean
it's nice um so
bear john asked me before we
agreed to do this talk would i do this
in practice
um and the answer to that is
yes maybe no
maybe yes maybe i don't know
the reason for this is that um
there is not really a library that we
found that really does
all this stuff for you in an easy to
read easy to write way
yes there are libraries that very much
look like you have sharp
implementation on the right just do the
bind with a nice
operator instead of doing all this bind
and manually
that's true um but languages like f
sharp and scala
also come with a lot of very nice
features in terms of
compile time checking and all that kind
of stuff
and writing all that stuff in python is
possible
but it's a lot of work and we haven't
found anything that does this out of the
box for you automatically
um so if this were if this were properly
implemented in the library
that had type in supports um with
composition time
type checks so the time that you
actually run the code
um to start up unicorn or your
whatever it would just tell you that
some of your compositions are wrong
they'll be very useful that's not really
present yet um also you need a very nice
and polished api like you see in the
right because
writing all this bind map compose
really does clog up the code again and
it takes away from the very nice
experience that you might have if you
were to write in another language
so would i do it maybe
we need another session like this so
another session like this to
hash out this detail um it's also good
to note that
we went through the concepts very
quickly today we really really hammered
out the details
so we could fit all the all this
information that we just
saw in this talk which was an hour long
into 30 minutes so we did skip a lot of
partners
um if you think this is interesting but
you didn't understand
anything we said i completely understand
um look at look up the original talk
it's very
i would say very fun to watch it's very
intuitive
guys a very good guy um yeah
links to the slide links in the slide
and uh for the
some for the more advanced uh curious
programs i would say also look at for
example biomass no slash
they implement actually the underlying
functional concepts of
the thing we just discussed during this
talk but use the
functional lingo yeah if you find with
functional lingo
then go um i've seen we have one
question from the audience
um there's a lot of branching any
thoughts on the kind of
performance trade-offs maybe there are
certain class programs where
it works better than other approaches
any thoughts
a lot of branching
let's let's go to slide where we here
with respect to performance i don't
think there's an issue here because
basically what happens in all these
functions is that as soon as we
hit the failure track function
the the value is just passed on there
are no function calls anymore
that will be just a function call from
updatedb
the actual function call when you have
success case from canonicalize well
that's always the case in this
particular case no that's not always the
case if validate fails
the value will just be passed on it will
just be
simple i don't see any performance
hits there no um yeah it depends
on you guys if of course if you were to
replace your numpy account with this
then you would then i would say no but
if you were to just
move from python to this kind of python
it doesn't
really include any overhead you're sure
you have a bit of function goals but
i i wouldn't i don't see any real
areas where there's a lot of overhead to
be honest
um
different question is so the main goal
slash benefit of this is to have
reusable blocks and centralized error
exactly
yes yeah definitely that yeah i think
this is a
one of the nice examples is this one so
here we basically implement the concept
we were working on
so this real world concept we are
implementing map here
and when implementing math we realized
hey this looks very familiar to us we
already had this at that function and
a success of an f is basically a
function composition
and when you realize these things that
your program
is basically not more than a composition
of functions
you end up in one lineus like this where
you can abstract away a lot of
implementation details of how things are
done by just composing function
and i i believe that to be a very
interesting way of programming
interesting way of constructing your
programs as
you create it has the opportunity to
greatly reduce the number of lines you
need to
achieve what would normally yeah require
much more lines of code
yeah um where do you see the difference
to a from this implementation to a
promise implementation
uh what we basically
shown here is an either implementation
another promise implementation a promise
is about
computation in the future which will
return a result in the future that's a
different concept i would say
it has relationships to this but
not one was easily explained in the same
terms of a
real-world trial how difference is this
from calling the error track
exception in python would this provide
any guarantees you wouldn't get
with procedural card with exceptions
yeah this interesting question
we had this discussion over and over
again between the two of us
so as soon as you start throwing
exceptions you will
lose the you will lose the benefits of
the composition
because then if you assume that any
function is a
can be a composition of other functions
but you also have to assume that
any of those compose functions could
throw an exception somewhere
then you always end up dealing with the
return values which can be either
success or failure
but still also wrap it in a try except
to deal with exceptions happening there
and i believe that dealing with values
in the long term is easier to reason
about and that makes your
software more maintainable so to say and
as an engineer that's what i'm looking
for is my software maintainable enough
dealing with exceptions is a possible
way and i know it's very common in
in python but i i believe that the the
way we present this here is very doable
as well
and has some long-term benefits which we
have seen in
in other languages as well yeah
okay i believe that that's all the open
questions we have
i think so too um well that's a
nice presentation also very impressive
to
fit a one-hour ideas from our
presentation into half an hour
um well it's a nice overview how you can
do
a lot of flexible stuff with a small
number of building blocks so
well thank you very much for uh this
talk
and well if there are any other
questions you'll be available in the
discord
definitely thank you very much for
having us thanks for having us and
thanks for attending
yeah well thank you